gros plans 12 à troisième la belle et la
bête est un des films que je préfère est
donc je suis plus fier en dehors de moi
bien entendu dans les critiques disait
d'ailleurs que mon interprétation
n'était valable que grâce au masque de
la bête
ce masque il fallait cinq heures chaque
matin pour coller sur mon visage
chacun de ces pansements poil et mes
dents étaient maquillés au vernis noir
des crocs ils étaient adaptés et ses
gros de carnivores interdisait de manger
toute autre chose que des purées ou des
compotes jean cocteau me donnait chaque
jour un exemple de bonté et de patience
il portait aussi un masque
il était très malade d'une maladie de
peau qui durera six ans et qui
commençait à ce moment-là et de la paie
10 go de l'urticaire ou de l'eczéma
défieront d anthrax un flegme ans tous
avec sa barbe qui ne pouvaient pas rasé
formé un autre genre de masque beaucoup
plus terrible que bien malgré sa
souffrance et son inconfort il rester de
bonne humeur il plaisantait pour créer
une atmosphère d'amitié et de gaieté
elle me disait que le bon dieu le
punisse est de me faire souffrir
m'obligeant à porter ce masque en lui
envoyant un dans un autre genre
à ce propos ne trouvez vous pas bizarre
que tout le monde cherche à être beau
physiquement et qu'il est à la portée de
n'importe qui d'être beau moralement et
que personne n'a fait la gymnastique
d'ailleurs n'est-ce pas au fond le sujet
de la belle et la bête